on prend soin de l'eau distillée soit de
l'eau minérale pour fabriquer de l'eau
mais pour fabriquer quoi à la Maison de
l'Environnement de Manille et hameaux
ces chimistes en herbe apprennent à
fabriquer du dentifrice maison un
dentifrice 100% naturel et contrairement
aux idées reçues c'est un jeu d'enfants
de cuillères à soupe d'argile blanche
une cuillère à café de bicarbonate 2
cuillères à café d'eau et pour le goût
quelques gouttes d'huile essentielle
apparemment tout le monde n'est pas
encore au point mais à l'arrivée on doit
obtenir cette pâte blanche un atelier
ludique proposé par l'association petit
débrouillard pour inciter les enfants et
leurs parents à utiliser moins de
produits chimiques il n'y a pas de
conservateur c'est très respectueux de
l'environnement donc on intervient sur
le principe de la chimie verte la chimie
donc qui n'emploie pas de produits
toxiques un moyen également de payer
jusqu'à 5 fois moins cher son dentifrice
selon l'association alors la chimie
verte a-t-elle convaincu aujourd'hui oui
je refais parce que ça m'a vraiment
beaucoup plu et pour ceux qui voudraient
tenter la recette ce dentifrice se
conserve deux semaines au réfrigérateur